RAHUL HARPALANI: Hi.
This presentation is
Observability Best Practices
for Reliably
Running Apps on VMs.
I'm Rahul Harpalani, but
my friends call me Harp.
I'm a product manager at Google
Cloud focused on observability,
and specifically
telemetry, which
is the capturing of metrics and
logs to enable ops management.
I'm joined here by
my partner Ling.
Ling, would you like
to introduce yourself?
LING HUANG: Sure thing.
Hey, everyone.
My name is Ling.
I'm so glad to be here today.
And I'm working very closely
with Harp on the cloud ops
instrumentation
efforts, driving mainly
from the technical side
as the TO of the team.
And you're going to see
me again at the demo time
towards the end of
this presentation.
Harp, I'm going to hand
it back to you now.
RAHUL HARPALANI: Thanks, Ling.
In this presentation, we'll be
walking through observability
within virtual machines.
Recently, the 2021
Report on Accelerating
the State of DevOps
found that teams
who excel at modern
operational practices
are 40% more likely to
report greater software
delivery and
operational performance
and 80% more likely to report
better business outcomes when
they fully invest in
managing operations at scale.
So, as you can see, setting
up logging and monitoring
and making sure you're
collecting the right
telemetry data is the
first important step
of day-two operations.
This helps you run a reliable
application and triangulate if,
when, and where
something went wrong.
As a foreshadow, we're
going to focus a lot
on the value of our agent.
There are many great resources
for deeper dives into the Cloud
Ops Suite for visualization,
alerting, and other logging
and monitoring capabilities.
I recommend you go
to YouTube and search
"Stack Doctor" to learn more.
There is a lot of buzz around
containers and Kubernetes,
but many of us are still
running on VMs and plan
to do so for the
foreseeable future.
Especially as more
customers are doing
a lift-and-shift migration from
their on-prem environments,
we often hear, how can
I set up my applications
and VMs to run on the cloud
while simultaneously learning
all the features Google
Cloud has to offer?
Running apps reliably
on VMs does not
happen without good telemetry.
Data about your applications,
about your processes,
about your systems are essential
to delivering a high quality
experience.
I'm going to spend roughly
the next 10 minutes walking
through some of the challenges
that I constantly hear about.
I'll review the
guiding principles
we use in VM observability
to address these challenges.
Then I'll give an
overview of the Ops
Agent, the single client-side
solution for logging
and monitoring.
We'll then get a
demo from Ling, where
she'll walk through
installing the Ops Agent using
popular open-source
configuration tooling.
And finally, we'll leave
some time for questions.
All right.
Let's jump in.
As a product manager, some
questions I often ask our users
are, are you running VMs in
more than one environment?
Are you operating in hybrid
or a multi-cloud environment?
What solutions are you using
for monitoring versus logging?
Do you have to leverage
multiple client-side agents
to capture telemetry?
And what tools are you
using to provision,
install, configure,
and manage your agents?
These questions usually
lead to one conclusion--
complexity.
Simply put, users
have tons of VMs
that need to be instrumented
with one or more agents.
These agents need to be
managed with one or more tools,
and even the
thought of migration
can be stress inducing.
Let's quickly
visualize this to put
this problem in perspective.
Often we think of only
our own environments.
And despite this downscoping,
it still can be hectic.
When we start to think about
all the permutations I just
discussed beyond
our own workloads
and think about this
issue at enterprise scale
with tens of thousands of
VMs, the problem of complexity
becomes glaring.
For this reason, the integration
between Google Cloud and Cloud
Ops is a game changer
in reducing complexity,
and why we at Cloud Ops
believe having an integrated
solution that meets
you where you are
is very important in helping
you manage and reduce
your ops burden.
When we think about
simplification,
we think about the agent.
For this reason, we
embraced several principles
in making our latest
agent, the Ops Agent,
industry leading in its
user-friendly focus.
Fewer agents-- this starts
right here at Google Cloud.
Up until a couple
of months ago, we
had two agents, one for
logging and one for monitoring.
We've invested heavily
in a single unified agent
to reduce the number of
agents and complexity
our users must manage.
Number two, the ability to
manage our agents at scale
by investing in solutions
to easily support the most
popular config-management
tools that most of our users
are already leveraging.
Simple configuration--
the Ops Agent
only has one
configuration file, making
it simple to manage both
logging and monitoring.
Finally, third-party
application support--
here at Cloud Ops,
we're making the move
from monitoring the
platform to also monitoring
popular applications.
We don't think
that requiring you
to install extra agents or extra
software to capture this data
is something that makes sense
or is a good use of your time.
So we're building this
capability into the Ops Agent.
One thing that's
not on this slide
and is crucial to
our strategy is
our investment in open source.
We know the overall
story to telemetry
is not cutting it for
all operations users.
And that includes our own users,
as well as everyone else's.
Customers are simply
juggling too many agents,
too many protocols, and too
many ways to capture telemetry.
In this vein, we decided to go
beyond a new agent and stake
out a path forward that would
make capturing telemetry
easier for all of our users.
And we are doing this by
committing and supporting
open observability standards.
The Ops Agent is
built to support
the future of
application and system
telemetry, which is
being democratized
through open source.
We've incorporated two important
open-source technologies
into the Ops Agent.
First, Fluent Bit.
Fluent Bit is an open-source
log processor and forwarder,
which allows you to collect logs
with incredibly high throughput
and resource efficiency.
The second technology
is OpenTelemetry.
This is a CNCF-supported,
open-source,
and vendor-neutral technology
and is at the forefront
of unifying operations.
It has garnered the support of
many vendors in the op space.
And the Cloud Ops Agent
emphasizes our belief
that this technology will
lead to interoperability
within the ops community.
We've worked very close with
the OpenTelemetry community.
And through this effort, much
of which is frontier territory,
we are helping to guide
the greater telemetry
community to a place that is
optimized for you, the user.
I mentioned these
topics earlier,
but I wanted to
specifically call out
how we are meeting our
users where they are.
What I hear from
customers all the time is
that they are overwhelmed
with all of the tools
they have to manage
and learn to use.
That's why we made sure that
the Ops Agent could be managed
by the open-source configuration
and provisioning tools
that you're already using, such
as Terraform, Ansible, Puppet,
and Chef, and of course, our
in-house option, VM Manager.
In the demo, which
Ling will run shortly,
you will see the
installation of the Ops
Agent handled by Ansible.
Additionally, I
mentioned the support
for third-party applications.
Currently we support
Nginx and JVM.
But we have an aggressive
rollout schedule
for the rest of this year
to include Apache, MySQL,
Redis, and many more.
In 2022, we're going
to increase the support
by 50 additional third-party
applications directly built
into the Ops Agent.
Finally, I want to review
our integration with GCP.
While the Ops Agent is built
on OpenTelemetry and Fluent Bit
for the efficient
collection of telemetry,
it is purpose built to support
our own operations suite,
which includes cloud
monitoring and logging.
With the operations suite, we
want you to have reliability
without sacrificing agility.
As you'll see in the demo, data
from cloud logging and cloud
monitoring is made available
directly in context
in Google Compute Engine.
And many other GCP services
have similar integrations.
Time for the demo.
Ling, are you ready?
LING HUANG: Ready for a demo.
So in this demo, we're
going to show you
how to use the Google
Cloud Ops Agent Ansible
role to install the Ops
Agent on the fleet of VMs
and then configure Ops Agent
to monitor Nginx applications.
And at the end of
the demo, we are
going to go to the console UI.
So that way, we can show you
how to pull the Nginx dashboard
template and create a
real dashboard out of it.
So other details
of this tutorial
can be found on our
public documentation site
as well, just so you
can check it out later.
Now, let's get started.
In this demo environment,
I have already
finished installing some basic
setups, so that those parts are
tedious and not fun to watch.
So I installed Ansible.
I installed the Google
Cloud Ops Agent role.
I set up our service
account for the project,
downloaded the service
account key to my workstation,
and set up an environment
variable for it.
I also finished
setting up my local SSH
key, which is what Ansible will
be using to talk to the VMs.
So let's go to the
actual fun stuff.
First, let's take a look at
the Ansible inventory we have.
So here we are using
a plugin called
gcp_compute to help
manage the GCP VMs.
This plugin uses the service
account to authenticate.
And it will list all the VMs
in the lingshi-sandbox project.
And it will also show the
public IP of those VMs.
And Ansible will later
use these addresses to SSH
into those VMs.
Before we kick off this
playbook, let's first
ensure that Ansible can actually
successfully talk to those VMs
we are targeting at.
So we can use Ansible
to quickly ping
them to make sure they are.
The connection is alive.
Cool.
Great.
The connections-- looks OK.
So now let's dive a little
bit into the actual Ansible
playbook.
I'll actually--
let me double-check
that the installation of the
Ansible role is successful.
Yeah.
I already installed this before,
so it's already installed,
as it shows.
The examples playbook we are
using today looks like this.
Looks pretty simple, right?
We are basically asking
Ansible to install the latest
version of Ops Agent with
a custom configuration file
on all the hosts that we
have in the inventory.
Now, you might wonder, what is
in that ops-agent-config.yml?
Well, that's a good question.
Basically, our Ops
Agent by default
collects some system
metrics and logs.
However, we can customize it to
collect more logs and metrics
from third-party applications.
And in this example, we
are collecting metrics
and logs from Nginx.
On the metrics
side, I have already
pre-installed
Nginx on those VMs,
and their metrics expose via
their stub status module.
So the key in this
configuration part
is to make sure that Ops Agent
knows basically which URL it
should be using to talk to their
stub status module of the Nginx
application to
collect the metrics.
And then, on the
logging side, we
collect both Nginx access
logs and Nginx error logs.
OK, let's quit this, and
now it's the exciting part.
Let's actually
execute the playbook.
So the start of the
playbook execution
is going to take a few minutes.
Well, actually, I have
executed this playbook already,
so this should return just OK.
And while it's running, we
can go to the console UI
and take a look at
the actual dashboard.
So you can reach this page
via the monitoring dashboards.
And the sample library has
our Nginx template already.
So if you click on this, you
can go to this Nginx overview
and preview what the
dashboard looks like.
Here, we're going to
skip that and just import
the sample dashboard.
So it will automatically
create a dashboard for you.
It has a few metrics
that's tracking already.
And you can show
that it's tracking
the few VMs we created before.
And it shows the total requests
coming to the Nginx server.
It shows the
current connections.
It also shows the history
of the connections.
And of course, you can
also edit this dashboard
or add more charts
to this dashboard,
because Nginx does ingest more
than just these three metrics.
On the other side, we mentioned
before that Ops Agent also
collects some system metrics.
So the most interesting one
might be the processes metrics.
If we go to the dashboard
list, there is GCP dashboard,
and one of them
says VM Instances.
If we go to this
page, it shows you
our few tabs of different
property of the VMs.
You can see CPU metrics, memory
metrics, and most excitingly,
you can see processes metrics.
They will tell you the
top processes by memory,
the top processes by CPU.
So that way, we can
easily tell what
is using all the
resources on the VM
and what could
potentially go wrong.
That's the dashboard part.
Now let's go back to see if
that execution of playbook--
OK, it looks great.
The execution of the
playbook was successful.
And that's actually
the end of this demo.
Thank you so much.
RAHUL HARPALANI: Thank
you so much, Ling,
for that awesome demo.
As a reminder to those
of you tuning in, please
use the
question-and-answer forum,
which is embedded
in this video page.
I want to take a
minute to show you
other interesting presentations
in the operation space
that are happening
at Next this week.
We're launching a preview
of fully managed Prometheus
service called Managed
Service for Prometheus.
If you were running
Kubernetes, chances
are that you're very
familiar with Prometheus
and how difficult
it can be to manage.
This new service takes away the
pain of Prometheus at scale.
We are also launching
a preview of a service
that combines logs
data with the power
and performance of BigQuery.
You can learn more
about Log Analytics,
what it is, and the use
cases in that presentation.
Finally, the integrated
Cloud Ops story,
where we talk about
how Ops Tools can
be used to make your development
team and the apps they
run more effective.
I'd like to thank
Ling for the demo
and thank our viewers
for tuning in.